hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Ninja Turtles 2 video I'll be
talking about Easter eggs so when I get
to that part I'll just say spoiler
warning so here we go
so let's do the non spoilery stuff first
they changed a whole bunch of stuff
about the last film so you might notice
some visual things like the design of
the turtles themselves as well as the
way they handle some of the characters
from the first film they recast a few
people especially the shredder
there's a different shredder Bryan T
wasn't in the last film and I think it
was a good decision Bryan T is a great
actor and they also recast the voice of
Leonardo if you guys didn't know Johnny
Knoxville did the voice of Leonardo in
the first film which might sound
baffling to you why does it sound like
Leonardo's smoked for cigars before this
scene started so mercifully they fixed
that part a lot of the actors are doing
the voices for the turtles themselves so
the people that do the motion capture
those are the voices that you're hearing
the only exception to that is splinter
it's still Tony Shalhoub doing the voice
of splinter which did seem kind of like
a strange choice to me when the first
film came out but there were also some
story issues with the first film like
not to dig in too deeply to the old film
that they kind of brushed over in this
film so we think they were able to
course-correct this movie by digging
deep into the classic cartoon series as
well as the comics if you haven't read
the comic that actually started in 1984
which I didn't really read till after I
saw the first movie like I think I saw
the movie first then I watched the
cartoon series then I went back and read
the comic which is actually amazingly
adult compared to the tone of the
cartoon series as well as these movies
so if you've been watching arrow for a
long time it might have seemed strange
to see Stephen Amell do so much comedy
so it took me a sec to adjust his
character because he's so used to
playing alpha male characters and Casey
Jones is so not an alpha male on this
he's more like Roy Harper in terms of
his superhero development so this
version of Casey Jones isn't quite as
fully realized as the version from the
classic movies but if you've seen any of
the other Turtles material I've seen any
of the movies the classic movies the
classic cartoon series read the comic I
felt like they were pretty faithful to
those there were a few minor changes
that they did try to modernize it just a
little bit and there was a whole bunch
of Transformers in there so they had a
little bit of fun I definitely think
they'll end up making a third film so
more power to Stephen Amell
congratulations glad to see you breakin
into the big movies maybe in the next
movie we can do saga you Jimbo
from another dimension so we can have
ninja rabbits play with Ninja Turtles
really the turtles are the star of this
film so even though you have humans like
Steven Amell Megan Fox really the
turtles are the ones that dominate the
screen time but getting despoilers now I
wanted to talk a little bit more about
Casey Jones character that involves
spoilers so here we go one of the only
things that bug me about Casey Jones
character was the way they surfaced him
in the film so instead of being the
street level hockey enthusiast that you
see from the comics or the original
movies or even the cartoon series they
make him a correctional officer like
they try to surface him in law
enforcement
and he just feels a little too clean-cut
one of the reasons why he works so well
with the Turtles as a character is
because he's an outsider just like they
are metaphorically he's a turtle that
just happens to look like a human so
effectively he becomes an honorary
turtle and I feel like that did not
happen in this film and I think that's
largely Michael Bay's influence because
even though Michael Bay didn't direct
this film the directors of the film come
from Michael Bay's production company so
that's why you saw so much transformer
stuff in I'll talk about it when I get
to Easter eggs in a second but I feel
like there's potential if he comes back
for another film they can just crunch
him up a little bit make him a little
bit more of an outsider amongst other
humans so that he feels like he fits
with the Turtles who were Outsiders
themselves a little bit better the
spirit of a turtle in the body of a man
so he becomes honorary turtle you get
the idea but a couple big Easter eggs so
Stephen Amell actually dropped a big
Easter egg for the comic book when he
said the turtles are from New Hampshire
when they were in the interrogation room
Laura Linney's like where do these
turtles even come from and he's like I
don't know New Hampshire that's where
the comic book was created in the 80s
when he's in the bar interrogating the
guy from the spring commercials he
breaks open the jukebox it's playing the
Vanilla Ice song from the original
Turtles movie we got bebop and
Rocksteady Krang the Technodrome pretty
much look exactly like they do in the
classic cartoon series all the Krang
scenes totally took me back to my
childhood it felt like right out of that
classic cartoon series talking about
transformer stuff there was a whole
bunch of transformers that whole
Technodrome scene was totally out of a
Transformers movie it was like turtles
turned into a Transformers movie in the
last act but there was even the
bumblebee cosplayer with the transformer
sound effect in the song the plate over
the end credits
was a mash-up of Vanilla Ice's ninja rap
from Turtles too as well as the theme
song from the cartoon series so if
anything I feel like most of the Easter
eggs in the film and most of the tone of
the film was informed by the classic
cartoon series and I feel like they did
a much better job of being true to that
than the last
you know big a live-action Turtles film
which felt like a vast departure but I
will say I still feel like the classic
Turtles films did a better job of
capturing the zeitgeist at the time
that's why they feel a little dated
because creatively they were just so
much of that time like late 80s early
90s the turtles were written that way in
the comics they were ninjas who were
Turtles who talked like 80s surfer dudes
in today in 2016 that's a little more
anachronistic it'd feel really weird if
someone were walking down the street
talking like an 80s surfer dude today
let me know what you guys thought of the
film if there are any other Easter eggs
that I forgot to mention so what's gonna
happen next is Geoff Johns just dropped
a big Justice League bomb he was talking
about the title everybody's wondering
there are all these rumors so be sure to
subscribe to get that video I'll explain
what's going on but Justice League
tomorrow as well as flash I got a new
flash video that I'm working on to wait
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here to learn all about
Marvel's phase 3 timeline all the Marvel
phase 3 movies and you can click here to
learn all about guardians of the galaxy
- thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight